welcome to designing in the browser and
this seriously explore how to take a
design build it and then tweak it in the
browser using the latest and we have
technology and design systems today
we're talking all about typography on
the web we're talking about type systems
and about variable fonts the new
frontier and web typography it's such an
exciting time to be designer on the web
so let's dive in you excited that a
[Music]
typographic scale is super important for
readability and consistency when
designing a website or system the
material design type scale includes a
range of contrasting styles that support
the needs of your product and its
contents it looks like this material
design components for the web is the web
based implementation of material design
within it you can implement the material
type system in two ways the first is by
using classes I have the starter kit
pulled up here to show you what that
looks like
you can set MVC typography on the parent
elements the body class for example as
we have here to get this default
typefaces liked Roboto or whatever style
you set those in the theme to propagate
within that element on the page so here
I have this set on the body class and
even though in the paragraphs I'm not
specifying a typography style we're
still getting a Roboto as the typeface
if I remove this class here you can see
that we're removing those base styles
from this entire element including those
paragraph styles then you can specify
more specific class names on individual
elements to specify that style further
for example here we have an h1 or a
header one elements with the headline 3
styling applied to it so here I've
applied this MVC typography headline 3
class to give it that tender graphic
style inside our class tool this class
palette and dev tools we can start
typing MVC - typography to sort of get
an auto-fill for the typographic styles
I talked about this in the previous
episode about dev tools so in here we
can start to play and see what these
various hyper graphic Styles look like
and this is especially nice if we've set
up a fee
and we're testing styles on that theme
within the page so if I wanted to do the
same thing with paragraphs I would go
here I would start typing embassy
typography and the body 1 & 2 would
automatically pop up as autocomplete so
I could have a much nicer styling based
on the material system using this type
of graphic style and the kids sort of
this tracked out style and also a bit
more space inside of that text body
there this allows for separation of
logic which is your data and markup and
style so I can have that habit line 3
style on an h1 so technically it's an h1
which is how screen readers read that
browsers will parse it but the user will
see a headline 3 style same thing with
the paragraph same thing with any other
element inside of our page the second
way to incorporate material design
typography is by using the module system
so here we have an example English of
the material starter kit and inside of
the my components file you can see that
I'm applying the headline one style
headline two style headline through
style etc through mix-ins this means
that I don't necessarily need to apply
classes to every single individual
element but I'm setting the base style
for all the h1 h2 h3 s on this page to
be pulling from the MTC typographies
style so when we look at the mark-up
here we simply have an h1 and a
paragraph and all of these elements
without having to adjust classes but
these elements are still getting that
style I could go in here and override
this so I can always add a class here to
be MDC typography headline 3 and that's
because I'm still having the option of
having these additional classes here and
so if i refresh this you can see that
we're getting the headline 3 style even
though we have the h1 set Roboto is a
nice default but we don't want every app
to look the same
so let's customize our typeface and
sizing luckily there's a massive free
resource of typography ready for the web
called google fonts
so you can access Google Fonts by going
to Fahnestock google.com and on this
website we have variety of fonts you can
adjust what you're looking for you can
change what the sentence is so here we
have a sentence that shows you upper
case lower case you get your ascenders
and descenders but if I wanted to write
Disko is the best pup then this is the
text I'm looking for if I had a headline
for example I'd want to be looking for a
specific text or a specific phrase then
I can adjust that and test with that for
use you could change the size of what
that looks like you can select various
categories so I could look for maybe
only sans-serif typefaces and now I'm
looking at only sans-serif typefaces you
could break this down look for
handwriting typefaces you can see a lot
of interesting handwriting aesthetics on
here but I'm going to stick to
sans-serif you can also set the font
properties so you could look for a
number of styles or feed a lot of
various types of styles so here I'm
setting only typefaces with 13 15 17 18
plus styles these are really robust
typefaces and fonts you can set the
thickness of this font so that could be
something that's really thick and wide
or thin width is another option here say
could set these wide typefaces or
something it's a little bit more narrow
its slant there's another option so how
much you want that to be slanted so
ideas here there's a lot of fun
properties that you can adjust to your
needs
so let's roll through here and look at
all of our different options we've got
some nice ones maybe we want to use
let's say fira sans this looks like a
nice typeface let's use this specimen so
I'm going to click on the plus this will
select the family and now we can add
this to our fonts I've copied the font
and now I want to use that in a custom
theme to see how it propagates in our
components so in order to do that I can
open up the material theme builder so
here I've got that opens up I'm gonna
hit create a new theme in the bottom
right corner and it's going to open up
this new glitch project right and then
play with the colors typography etc in
this theme I'm gonna open up the my
theme file and this is where I'm going
to replace the Roboto typeface with my
theater sans typeface I also want to
update this
within the MVC typography font family so
I'm gonna say Fira sans is what I want
to use here as my typography font family
and then I'm going to open this in a new
window so I can see what that looks like
so here it is a subtle change but now I
have fear of sans as the new updated
headline if I wanted to make this
something that was completely different
then I can make you a fantasy typeface
or something like that so you want to go
into google fonts just to find a very
different typeface
let's select display let's pick let's
pick this stencil one I'm gonna add that
to the specimen and when you open this
you can see what the load time looks
like for these two typefaces if that
load is heavy then we can select a
specific type face weights that we need
and then that's gonna be what we're
sending but I no longer want to use the
first typeface I only want to use this
embedded stencil Thyra stencil one I'm
gonna copy and paste this into my theme
and this only has one weight so we don't
have to worry about that specifying that
and I'm going to copy this text here and
update this to Cyrus stencil one gonna
go back to my theme builder and we fresh
it's gonna take a minute to update that
typeface and here we go I have this
Cyrus ensel one theme legibility here
might be a little difficult on smaller
sizes so just be aware that when you're
choosing your typefaces now if I really
wanted to adjust these typefaces
individually instead of adjusting all
the typefaces and the entire application
to use the same typeface we can use SAS
maps for that so I'm just gonna get rid
of the rest of the theming in here so
you can see very clearly what I'm doing
and I'm pasting in these style overrides
so for all of the button Styles here I'm
setting the font size and the text
transform to being none so they're not
uppercase anymore I'm
setting headline one styles to be that
font family that I want to use instead
of making this global I'm only gonna set
it on the h1 h2 and H 6 and then I'm
adjusting the font size and weights here
although here the weight doesn't really
matter because we only have one weight
so let me remove that just to show you
have the option to use weight but it
doesn't really make sense here so now in
this application when i refresh you
could see in the steam summary on the
left hand corner I have the h1 the h2
and the h6 using this Cyrus stencil one
typeface h3 h4 h5 and the body copy
using our Roboto typeface as the default
and then the buttons no longer have that
text transform uppercase so you really
have a lot of control over these
individual styles for your various
headlines captions the rest of the
typography on your page by using sass
maps within your material design theme
mixing typography can really create a
nice separation of hierarchy in your UI
and there are a lot of great resources
out there to help with font pairings
using the free Google Foss one of those
is fought paired SEO and here are a few
of the featured pairings I love this
page because it showcases various google
fonts in you eyes that have been laid
out with colors style etc and you can
see how they look really nice which ones
look nice together in terms of weight
style width slant etc so I'd recommend
looking these up and playing around with
the font pairings yourselves making
those decisions inside of the Google
Fonts tool the tools are out there for
you and it's really up to Union
creativity to decide the aesthetic of
your application now let's talk about a
very cool and relatively well supported
new technology sweeping the web font
nation variable funds variable fonts let
you compress express and finesse your
designs the primary change is at
variable funds that you access all of
the variations contained in a given font
file by a CSS and a single app Fontes
reference that means there are a ton of
creative and potential performance
benefits to using this new font format
before in a complex design a user would
have to load every font variation as
separate file italic bold
then etc that meant either a really
heavy page to load where the designer
would have to scale back the design to
only a few fonts with variable fonts the
user only has to load one or two Roman
italic font files to be able to use a
variety of styles note that using a
variable font doesn't always guarantee a
smaller font load for example system
fonts will always be speedy and
lightweight we're using only a few font
weights but for complex designs variable
fonts can make a very big difference
variable fonts are also interoperable
along for more customization and
expression you're not limited to font
weights at 400 600 and 800 anymore now
you can use 325 or 615 and weight is
just one potential axis you can also
specify slant and so many more various
axes based on that font no bottle flex
is an example of this this typeface lets
you specify various weights and play
around with that on this scale slider
the spacing and tracking of the typeface
you can have it really tracked out or
really tightly tracked the height of the
typeface so that's gonna be the
ascenders of that typeface sort of
scrunching down to be more closer to the
exciton that line the ascender is here
that are going to be extending even
further so if you look at that L the FS
in this the B sort of extending you
further the descenders you can specify
how tight or how far away from the
baseline you want those to be as well
this dicrotic distance this is gonna be
like the top of the eye for example a
mono space you have the spot become a
mono space typeface now you only have to
have one typeface as your mono space and
your regular serif or sans serif I think
that's super cool and then curvature the
curvature of this text can also be
adjusted here so this is an exciting
thing to see all of these various axes
on a single font face
variable fonts are smart and can even
apply their own optical size adjustments
for example a variable fonts are the
small size can track itself out make
itself a little bit bolder a little bit
easier to read here's an example of that
from Annie Michael I've opened up dev
tools that could resize the browser here
and as I'm resizing you can see that
this typeface is starting to become a
little bit more bold a little bit easier
to read at the smaller typeface here
this first pair gonna fear is getting
incrementally smaller as is the header
so you can see that we have these
obstacle adjustments that can be made
for larger browsers and smaller devices
to a larger browser is a thin typeface
might be easier to read at smaller
browsers that's gonna be hard to read
google fonts has a beta API to help you
along with using variable fonts today
here's an example of a paid API I made a
little demo on glyphs to show you what
it's like to use the Spade API if you
wanted to get started with it yourself
so the first thing that we have to do is
include this typeface via the Google
Fonts C the N so that's the link here
and now if we want to use all of the
weight options in the font variation
settings we would have to have the
weight and then at 200 this dot dot
specifies values in between to 900 so
here I'm including all of the values
from 200 to 900 so we'll be able to
interpolate between them and what does
that look like here we have that
typeface applied to a header and so I'm
going to inspect it to show you what it
looks like behind the scenes here we
have the swathe um a set of crimson pro
and here I have fought variation
settings of weights the weight axis at
625 and you can adjust this up and down
if you hit shift and the up and down
arrow keys inside of your dev tools it's
sort of a shortcut to let you adjust
these values so you can see here that
I'm adjusting these values from any
value this is at 275 now it's going very
light all the way up to 900 and it will
be able to interpolate all the values in
between and change to any of the weights
in between those values so you can get
really specific and finesse just the
perfect weight that you want a free
application this is only one simple axis
of weights but the possibility is can
get really extended like Novato flex
dico var has an example of how many
options
maxi's can emerge from one variable font
here is the website that showcases all
the different styles of deco bar all of
these different options and variations
here on the type network the coolest
thing here is you can select various
skeletons and these are all axes on
which you can transform this typeface
you can also set different types of
terminals and then also set the amount
of sort of expression on those terminals
as well you could have a slab font you
could have these really beautiful curved
out serifs and really start a plate you
have so many different types of
typefaces within one font file this is
why variable fonts are so exciting you
can really have so much control over
every little aspect of that typeface
inside of your application so it creates
this ability and opportunity for
expression for finessing and even for
some performance benefits when you do
have a lot of complex typography on a
website typography is such an important
part of your applications aesthetic
hierarchy and usability by pairing
typefaces nicely together and using a
type scale we can help guide our users
and make the content easy to understand
variable fonts are also really exciting
and provides so much more creative
freedom and even better performance for
our end users I hope that you've enjoyed
our show and learn something about using
web fonts for today and tomorrow what
are some of your favorite web fonts
leave a comment below we'd love to see
them until next time say bye
[Music]
you
[Music]